that same year mortal kombat came out
and you'd think we would have learned
our lesson with street fighter but the
fact is the advertising for this movie
was actually pretty good
it looked just like the game the special
effects were kind of cool and I had that
techno beat you can never get out of
your head we went as a Street Fighter
knowing it was going to be bad
but for Mortal Kombat we were suckered
in the West the main problem with this
film for more syllables pg-13 the game
was one of the most violent bloodbath to
ever hit the arcade and we all knew
there was no way they could fit all that
gore into a pg-13 movie which is a shame
because there's a lot of characters here
that could use a good decapitation where
do you get these guys the story centers
around three people Johnny Cage who
makes his living as a pretentious actor
Sonya who makes her living as a pouty
FBI agent and Liu Kang who makes his
living as a um Asian accompanying that
is a mystical something or other known
as Raiden played by Christopher Lambert
who sounds a little bit like Peter Lorre
after drinking a million sandpaper
martinis the great tournament was too
much responsibility responsibility
there's someone to do battle in a
supernatural tournament known as Mortal
Kombat spelled with a k not a C because
it's more threatening all of them
entered the tournament for different
reasons Sonya because she's after a
killer named Kano Johnny Cage because he
thinks it'll help his career and Liu
Kang because he's um Asia all these
characters are pretty annoying but
Johnny cages one-liners that really make
you want to kill yourself you want me to
carry your luggage I pay money you carry
the bags
thank God I'd ask him to park the car no
no no
mm the tournament is run by the
soul-sucking psychopath Shane song and
of course his goal is to that's right
take over the world of course where the
hell are we do I look like your travel
agent we find out later that Kano is
actually working for Shane song and it's
order to defeat Sonya at the tournament
like most of the characters in this
movie this guy could have been really
cool but unfortunately he talks you know
one-on-one man-to-man and to end oh come
on I just got done watching bandy and
don't put me through another annoying
accent almost lost my lunch I know the
feeling he's also accompanied by
fighters sub-zero who gives new meaning
to the term cold shoulder and scorpion
whose hand looks like a vagina being
penetrated will only does your squish
both these characters are pretty cool
but maybe that's because they don't talk
throughout the entire movie bro we know
they can have Jamaican accent or
something who's the big hot bag of em
who doesn't pee and doesn't care then
there's also the creature known as Goro
who's also serving Shang song and let me
tell you you can really tell you still
working on his forearms he said to be an
alien Prince but I don't know I think he
looks an awful lot like the human Prince
to me he's a pretty decent affect
despite the fact that slit movements are
about as accurate as a sock puppet this
beauty water would be milk oh wait a
minute
cage is about to do something funny
so Sonia defeats Kano Liu Kang defeats
this guy Raiden croaks up some more
advice and Johnny Cage even manages to
kill off Goro which is an act of
kindness after listening to a stupid
one-liners this is where you fall down
we also find out why Scorpion and
sub-zero don't talk scorpion turns out
is a fire-breathing skeleton it happens
and sub-zero is too busy pulling energy
from its crotch to defeat his enemies
hey if you had cold balls of fury like
that you won't be talking much either
exactly after that the film follows a
pretty standard format someone fights
rated talks someone fights Raiden talks
someone fights Raiden talks so what
exactly does he talk about but I hope
it's not so cliche like you must first
face your fears if you were to conquer
that you must first face your fears if
you are to conquer them fuck me this is
a dumb movie I'm no little tournament he
said be good for the career he said
later we find that Shang Tsung kidnapped
Sonya and forces her to fight him
instead of Liu Kang wait a minute what
happened to the brave and powerful Sonya
one second she's this fearsome warrior
and all of a sudden he put her arm
behind her back and it's Oh save me save
me he's too strong oh it's okay you know
you'll get out of it ah all right calm
down you'll think of something okay
chill I mean Jesus you're an effing
agent it's your job to get our
situations like this maybe actually tell
her she's not gonna be a Mortal Kombat
to go cheer up yet over yourself looking
for guidance our two heroes turn to
radom for some helpful advice I have
nothing further to teach you oh now you
shut the fuck up
the one time we actually need your
advice and you had another gift
what kind of Highlander are you anyway
sorry the least you can do is tell us
where he's taking her the ambrus castle
the emperors asshole
actually he was referring to the
mystical realms of Outworld and no that
is not another name for San Francisco
this horrifying dimension has the
incredible terror of knocked-over
statues knocked over statues and some
more knocked over statues oh and a
creature known as reptile who's kind of
like a mix between Finding Nemo and
Satan's ass I hope this leads to another
pointless action sequence
I love meaningless violence with no
rhyme or reason it reminds me of just
how boring the human imagination really
is brilliant after we see Sonya dressed
up in a skimpier costume which is
questionable but not problematic Shang
Tsung enters with a bunch of hooded
servants and we all know how this works
alright the good guys are going to be in
the robes they keep their head down so
you don't see them yeah okay the walk in
fear okay I make the evil speech we all
know the good guys are gonna pop up any
man you know can we just move this along
a little bit how long do we have to wait
here yes I know you're very evil and
everything come on can they just pop out
anytime maybe can you just hurry up and
send in the clowns already here ray
let's celebrate with more fighting
and how about a nurse stupid johnnycake
line
nice dress okay okay seriously no more
Johnny Cage jokes I just didn't trunk
anymore enough so Lu Kang to Fusheng
song rescue Sonia set free all the
little caspere goes and they live
happily ever after
or do they what is it
we pathetic fools I've come for your
soul I don't think so
well I do when the credits pop up that
means it's time to leave the theater
never look back at this horrible film as
long as you live now granted Mortal
Kombat isn't quite as bad as Street
Fighter but that's kind of like saying
being stabbed in the stomach isn't quite
as bad as testicular torture bottom line
these movies son the games are great but
these movies suck that tear a horrible
they're horrible if I had a choice of
seeing these movies again and crawling
across a street of broken glass on my
belly with my fly open only to be
greeted by a pack of rabid Wolverine to
not only want to eat me but also rave me
I'd probably see the movies again but
it's close very very close like a net
swing I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to